un grand rallye politique à la paz le
coeur historique de rio comme autrefois
le candidat de la gauche fernando haddad
du parti des travailleurs reçoit l'appui
de trois légendes de la chanson
brésilienne est à nos vélos saut chico
buarque mais la fausse note elle vient
du troisième le rappeur monobras je
n'aime pas ce climat de fête
l'aveuglément qui atteint les autres
nous atteint nous aussi ici c'est
dangereux il n'y a pas de quoi faire la
fête car le parti des travailleurs va
mal et fernando haddad se trouve dans la
situation impossible de défendre son
bilan tout en affichant sa fidélité à
son leader historique l'ancien président
ignazio lula da silva
car lula est en prison pour corruption
et cela réjouit les partisans du
candidat d'extrême droite gerb also know
qui en veulent à mort au parti des
travailleurs
dehors le pt distraire le gigantesque
scandale de corruption de la petrobras
les milliards de fonds publics détournés
a touché tous les partis traditionnels
mais davantage le pt car il était au
pouvoir
fernando haddad a fait une sorte de mea
culpa
la coop sont en cause un mouton est rare
et où la corruption est intolérable dit
il mais notre gouvernement n'a rien
caché sous le tapis et c'est notre
législation qui a permis d'accomplir
c'est pas excusable au contraire c'est
vrai pedro abramova ya été secrétaire à
la justice ou le gouvernement lula
il a vu ça de l'intérieur le pt s'est
concentrée sur la lutte contre
l'inégalité et la pauvreté mais rien
pour consolider la démocratie
il a fait des efforts énormes de créer
les mécanismes anti corruption mais
vraiment changer la manière me faire
politique au brésil
mais là rien fait pour ça et je crois
que les conséquences on l'a vu la taille
des scandales
l'ampleur des scandales fernando haddad
paie très cher pour cette négligence
mais ce n'est pas tout fois que l'entité
tisme il vient pas seulement de la
frustration légitime de la population
contre la corruption
il vient aussi d'une fausse route
nationale certaines parties de la
société qui voulait pas avoir les
politiques sociales implémenter donc ça
ça donc les c'est pour ça qu'on voit une
réaction qui vient vers la droite
la corruption a tellement discrédité
tous les partis politiques plus ou moins
modérée que la porte est grande ouverte
à un candidat totalement improbable
jaillir ball son art où il récolte sans
effort les fruits de l'immense
frustration des brésiliens jean michel
leprince radio canada rio de janeiro